[Música]
o ibope também definitivamente aprender
melhor
[Música]
não existe transformação que aconteça
sem aprendizagem envolvida não existe
nenhum processo de mudança que aconteça
sem aprendizagem envolvida
o que nos diferencia enquanto espécie é
a nossa capacidade de aprender inclusive
nos permitindo pensar que talvez a
aprendizagem tenha sido o que nos trouxe
até aqui enquanto espécie nos permitindo
desbravar e compreender o mundo numa
dimensão biológica cultural e até mesmo
tecnológica
agora eu particularmente gosta de pensar
de uma forma um pouco diferente
eu acho que na verdade as escolas nos
trouxeram até aqui enquanto espécie e
porque eu entendo escolas como
instituições absolutamente incríveis no
fundo que o papel de uma escola
organizar o conhecimento disponível no
mundo e que se julga o conhecimento
mínimo necessário e de direito de todos
os indivíduos para que todos os
indivíduos
ao acessar esses conhecimentos possam
realizar seus potenciais plenamente
escolas são instituições incríveis
porque conseguiram fazer isso de uma
forma absolutamente impressionante
talvez as escolas não existissem boa
parte talvez a imensa maioria do
conhecimento já produzido pelo ser
humano não teria sido compartilhado
teria se perdido ao conseguir aglutinar
e organizar esse conhecimento às escolas
potencializaram a capacidade do ser
humano de aprender
elas conseguiram também oferecer uma
escala do ser humano aprender sempre
na história da humanidade porém
atualmente as escolas enfrentam
problemas o que se esperava da formação
de uma criança de um jovem ao longo do
século 20 é muito diferente do que se
espera hoje em dia ea verdade é que hoje
em dia
espera-se muito mais essa diferença de
espectro de expectativa
iniciou uma crise nos sistemas
educacionais mundo afora
e essa crise deu origem a movimentos de
mudança e de reforma educacional tanto
em países quanto instituições
esses movimentos deram a possibilidade
de começarem a surgir escolas novos com
novas propostas com novas mentalidades
escolas preocupadas em desenvolver
habilidades que talvez fizessem mais
sentido para o futuro dos seus
estudantes do que para o passado e essas
escolas começarão a ser chamadas de
escolas inovadoras muito bem pra gente
dá conta de tentar responder à pergunta
que é o nome dessa palestra eu entendo
que a gente precisa conversar um pouco
sobre o cockpit do avião mas não
qualquer avião especificamente copo de
avião militar no final dos anos 50 um
fenômeno começou a aterrorizar os
engenheiros da força aérea
norte-americana aviões que não estavam
realizando procedimentos de guerra
eu acho que estavam realizando
procedimentos padrão começaram a cair e
seus pilotos começaram a morrer
nessas quedas a situação se tornou tão
crítica que em 1950
no mesmo dia e 70 pilotos morreram e
isso fez com que os engenheiros da força
aérea norte-americana começasse a
aventar as hipóteses para este acidente
eles acabaram chegando à conclusão de
que a razão provável residir em
problemas do design
pitico os aviões o cockpit ele é crucial
para uma boa experiência de pilotagem
afinal de contas um piloto militar ele
está tomando decisões em alta velocidade
o tempo todo realizando uma série de
tarefas em alta precisão
se ele precisar apertar três vezes um
determinado botão que deveria funcionar
pela primeira perto
isso pode ser suficiente para colocar
sua vida em risco se ele precisar ficar
mais a terra do planejado para fazer um
determinado pedal funcionar
isso pode ser o suficiente para que ele
perca visibilidade periférica e
equilíbrio provocando um acidente
o modelo que se utilizava no final dos
anos 50 havia sido projetado em 1926 a
partir de um grande estudo em que se
tornou as médias das medidas do corpo
dos pilotos e do braço e antebraço
tamanho da mão da perna do pé ea
hipótese dos pilotos é de que algum tipo
de mudança corporal havia acontecido e
portanto os pilotos não estavam mais
confortável dentro do cockpit não
conseguindo se mover de forma adequada e
realizar os procedimentos de forma
adequada
a força aérea norte americana então
convidou o professor recém doutor da
universidade harvard professor gilbert
danos e solicitou que ele conduzisse o
estudo que até hoje é o maior
quantitativo a mente falando com pilotos
na história da humanidade
ele selecionou 4063 pilotos e 1.140
dimensões de seus corpos
após esse resultado ele decidiu realizar
um teste
afinal a expectativa era de que a
maioria dos pilotos apresentassem
medidas dentro da média
o professor gilberto - então selecionou
as dez medidas mais importantes também
nos braços da mãe das mãos e comparou
essas dez medidas com cada uma das
medidas dos 4063 pilotos muito bem a
verdade é que nenhum absolutamente
nenhum piloto apresentou medidas
o da média e isso levou o professor
gilberto daniels a uma reflexão
importante
ele disse que o cockpit médio que
deveria funcionar para todos na verdade
não funcionava para ninguém porque na
verdade a idéia de piloto médio era uma
ideia errada que não existia
imagina você tem um piloto cujo braço
média 100 centímetros
o outro cujo braço média 80 a média vai
dar 90 mas nenhum piloto na vida real
tem um braço por 90 tem um com 80 tem um
conselho você vai desenhar um cockpit
que na prática não atende a ninguém
foi então que o professor brasileiro
pensou se é impossível desenhar um
cockpit para cada um dos mais de 50 mil
outros da força aérea
o caminho talvez seja personalizarem
massa personalizarem escala eu não vou
construir um cockpit onde a distância do
banco para o volante seja igual ou seja
adequada de acordo com o tamanho da
terra daquele piloto
eu criei um cockpit mas eu posso ajustar
a cadeira onde eu posso ajustar à
distância do comando onde eu posso
recriminar o banco
uma ideia que está presente no nosso dia
a dia hoje em dia acho que naquela época
nova e muito interessante
e assim foi feito o professor robert de
niro fez a seguinte afirmação ao final
do processo sistemas não deveriam ser
baseados na lógica da média muito bem
a questão é que as nossas escolas são
sistemas baseados em média
e quando falo média eu não estou me
referindo a nota média do final do ano
eu estou me referindo à média enquanto
lógica de padronização contínuo óbvio
você começou sua palestra dizendo que é
justamente essa lógica de padronização
que permitiu às escolas entregarem o
nível de aprendizagem de conhecimento
sem precedentes na história da
humanidade sim é verdade
esse sistema padronizado é caracterizado
por um modelo de todos aprender ao mesmo
tempo as mesmas coisas na mesma
velocidade independentemente do
interesse e do conhecimento
viu sobre aquele assunto a grande
questão é que o que antes
potencializavam hoje parece limitar toda
a padronização que nos permitiu ter
escolas no modelo de escala
hoje limita porque hoje o ser humano tem
uma capacidade de aprender maior neste
momento podem se perguntar jogo a
pergunta pra min thiago manual fazer se
a gente pensar sobre esse problema de
uma forma madura e racional
a gente vai entender que é isso
afinal de contas como você vai perceber
uma coisa personalizar um cockpit de
máquinas e equipamentos outra coisa é
personalizar a o que envolve seres
humanos ea proporção de estudantes é
muito maior do que a proporção de
educadores não tem como eu tenho um
educador por estudante ou mesmo um
educador para quatro estudantes não é
possível e essa idéia de impossibilidade
predominou a mentalidade de educadores
pesquisadores gestores educacionais no
mundo inteiro ao longo do século 20
havia um consenso de que era impossível
transformar esse modelo assim sendo este
modelo que nos trouxe até aqui
vamos tentar melhorar ele onde a gente
puder muito bem
isso foi verdade até o ano de 2001
no ano de 2001 acontece um fato que
transforma radicalmente a percepção das
pessoas sobre o que era eo que não era
possível fazer na educação em 2001
acontece a primeira edição do pisa um
exame internacional da o cd é que tinha
como objetivo mensurar as habilidades de
leitura pensamento matemático pensamento
de ciências de estudantes de 15 a 17
anos de idade dos países membros da
organização em torno de mais de 60 entre
60 e 70
naquela época a premissa central para
cima de qualidade de educação via da
economia percentual do pib investido em
educação
parte se do princípio que os países que
mais teriam os estudantes teriam os
estudantes que aprenderam mais
portanto se imaginava às vésperas da
divulgação do resultado do primeiro piso
que países como estados unidos alemanha
inglaterra frança japão apareceriam nas
primeiras posições do ranking pois
imaginava era senso comum a idéia de que
estudantes desses países eram os mais
inteligentes do mundo no dia da
divulgação do resultado
o mundo se a sombra porque quem apareceu
em primeiro lugar do ranking foi um país
encravado entre a escandinávia ea rússia
a finlândia
os jornalistas podem para helsinque para
escutar o pronunciamento do
primeiro-ministro finlandês ea primeira
pergunta é ministro
o que a finlândia fez para ter a melhor
educação do mundo para ter os estudantes
mais inteligente do mundo
ele responde de uma forma muito
transparente veja bem se você tivesse me
fazer essa pergunta que hoje de manhã eu
provavelmente diria que nós não temos a
melhor educação do mundo nem que nossos
estudantes são os mais inteligentes e
talvez qualquer educador nosso responder
da mesma forma mas o que eu posso dizer
para vocês aqui pelo menos algumas
décadas a finlândia vem realizando uma
série de mudanças importantes no seu
sistema educacional e na sua lógica de
pensar a educação a finlândia a partir
de uma premissa importante todos têm
necessidades especiais na escola
tradicional recebe atenção especial quem
fica abaixo da média o que os
finlandeses dizem é bom estudante que
fica abaixo da média ele precisa de
necessidade especial
afinal de contas tem uma lacuna de
conhecimento que precisa ser preenchida
por um estudante que fica acima da média
também precisa de necessidade especial
afinal de contas ele está demonstrando
uma aptidão eo talento num determinado
campo do conhecimento acima da média
portanto a personalização é necessária
para todos para quem tem dificuldade e
para quem tem potencialidades e
provavelmente um mesmo indivíduo um
mesmo estudante terá algumas
dificuldades
algumas potencialidades e precisa de uma
educação que dê conta disso porque é
isso que se espera hoje das escolas
portanto os finlandeses conseguiram
personalizar a aprendizagem de uma forma
muito similar aqui dos engenheiros
norte-americanos personalizaram o
cockpit
isso desencadeou a partir de 2001 a
partir do resultado do pisa uma onda de
inovações na aprendizagem porque o que
os americanos naturalmente e não
aceitaram bem o fato de que ficaram em
19º lugar na primeira edição do piso
assim como os alemães não aceitaram bem
o fato de ter ficado em 14º lugar e mais
do que isso
a finlândia mostrou ao mundo não só que
era possível fazer uma educação
diferente como também mostrou os
resultados da educação
os seus estudantes aprendiam mais
aprende o melhor e tinha uma relação com
o conhecimento diferente do que se
conhecia até então esses países
começaram a invadir a finlândia e tentar
entender o que eles estavam fazendo lá
que história é essa de um país que não
tem mais dever de casa num país que está
eliminando as disciplinas onde os
estudantes aprendem através de poetas
mas isso não foi apenas um movimento
governamental isso foi bem individual
a finlândia mostrou ao mundo que era
possível fazer a educação de uma forma
diferente e isso atraiu a atenção de
gente que originalmente lava com a
educação
designers desenvolvedores gente na área
de tecnologia empreendedores
pesquisadores dos mais diversos campos
as pessoas começaram a entrar na
educação e começaram a produzir
inovações da aprendizagem inovações como
a reivindicação educacional aprendizagem
adaptativa as metodologias ativas de
aprendizagem por projetos coaching
programação infantil aplicações da
realidade virtual da robótica e da
impressão 3d aplicações da inteligência
artifical da cultura maker inovações
essas que começaram a ser adotadas de
forma estruturada por parte de algumas
escolas
escolas essas chamadas de inovadoras
como a canon ad school na califórnia
como alto risco a primeira micro escola
do mundo nos estados unidos como a
escola da ponte em portugal a primeira
grande escola de projetos que se tem
notícia no mundo a vitra uma escola
sueca concederá de 2016 uma das mais
inovadoras do mundo mas essas escolas
começaram a surgir também aqui no brasil
escolas como um projecto âncora em são
paulo
como a escola leva no rio de janeiro
como a escola lumiar em são paulo já em
diversas outras cidades brasileiras
escolas como escola com centro de
ribeirão preto e salvador
e como também a escola recebe aqui em
juiz de fora
mas de fato essas escolas estão trazendo
alguma contribuição elas estão
melhorando o mundo de alguma forma o que
a gente pode pensar e refletir
é a partir dos insumos de trabalhos de
pesquisa trabalhos científicos que vem
procurando investigar os impactos e
resultados na aprendizagem do
desenvolvimento dos estudantes que
desenvolve a sua formação nessas
instituições e é muito interessante
porque o que se observa são graus acima
da média de autonomia e responsabilidade
um nível de engajamento e interesse nos
problemas do mundo e não apenas uma
visão individual interesses individuais
e pessoais nas suas questões de vida uma
familiaridade com o letramento digital
que está para além de saber usar a
tecnologia mas potencializar o uso da
tecnologia para resolução de problemas e
potencializar o uso da tecnologia para
evitar problemas para não se colocar em
risco nem colocar os outros em risco
assim como níveis de altruísmo e
habilidades de empatia e inéditos
basicamente uma revolução e termos de
novas habilidades cognitivas
em termos de novas habilidades
sócio-emocionais crianças e jovens
apresentando novas habilidades e
competências que historicamente crianças
e jovens não tinham essas escolas têm
permitido a formação de novas gerações
com capacidade acima da média
sob essa perspectiva tentar responder à
pergunta escolas inovadoras melhor um
mundo permanece sendo muito desafiador
na minha concepção o pra gente pensar é
que essas escolas estão ajudando a
formar gerações incríveis de seres
humanos e seres humanos incríveis são
capazes de tornar o mundo um lugar muito
melhor
muito obrigado pessoal
[Aplausos]
[Música]